what's going on guys
star wars the force awakens is nearly
upon us
I don't think I've ever seen a more
hyped movie we've all got the fever but
what if it stinks and we have to mega
star wars heads to hear to talk about it
with us first
he's one of the schmoes from schmoes no
and he is the host of colliders Jedi
Council Kristian harloff you're taking
me down the darkside path here and he's
the main man behind the laden media
michael barratt ii you venture deep into
star wars territory remind people about
your series of videos I have a what-if
series where I kind of go through and
realign the various components of the
prequels they're caught basically called
what-if episode 1 was good what if
episode 2 was good and if you want to
yeah and what if episode 3 were good is
coming out next Tuesday as today so
December 15 - yeah
so fellas we are at critical mass the
movies are gonna drop everyone's bought
their tickets it's done insane business
already
what if Wow no one's really talking
about this possibility I mean I am I
just Chicken Little here saying oh ok
what but no I don't think you're chicken
little because we all remember 1999 it
was like this all and then we're gonna
see this and all the first time attic is
Darth Vader and then you're just like me
so we said was it yeah I think everybody
behind Star Wars recognizes that while
people will certainly come back because
it is an established and beloved
franchise they they need to be careful
and they need to take good care of it
and I think that everybody is doing
everything and I mean if it's if it's
not good I riots in the streets is that
too far guys what if the chemistry in
this movie is like Anakin and Amidala
Daisy Ridley herself yes said that JJ
Abrams on the first day of shooting
called
her acting wooden obviously she must
have gotten better otherwise she
wouldn't have said that it's probably a
good thing because George Lucas never
commented on acting he just said okay do
your thing say your lines but the other
thing that is scary
if this thing stinks mmm is that it's
the
use of practical effects yeah it's the
reuse of a film so if JJ goes out and
makes such a big effort to use film
again and to use practical effects and
puppets and models and it stinks then
you're gonna see a flood of CGI Yann
well they try that you're walking out of
the theater and to borrow your term it
stinks yeah what's the first thing you
do do you call your mom what what
happens probably fall back on what I did
when Kingdom of the Crystal Skull came
oh no and you just go well in my mind
that's just not going to exist and hope
that maybe in the future now you're
scaring even the water there's two
scenarios yes the first one is what I do
what I did in 1999 I try to drink the
kool-aid of it and then say okay it's
good and then realize eventually it's
not or you just go alright rogue one
let's get here let's let's miss make it
up or you say okay Ryan Johnson
JJ couldn't do it can you if it is so
crushingly bad do you slink away quietly
or do you excoriate the film on social
media man I think you have to I think
you have to say like what were you guys
doing thanks for crushing dreams there's
a character like Jar Jar that pops up
there again there's really bad humor and
it doesn't fit then yeah you have to
Twitter allows us a certain public
defender role as far as media goes yes
if something is bad you can walk out of
it and go just like lower those
expectations are like expect third act
to not be exceptional going and everyone
can be like okay I would uh ask of
everyone on Twitter to try not to play
the internet extreme game when this
movie comes out because we tend to go
it's the best thing ever the worst thing
ever it can be an alright movie and we
can like recognize a few flaws and
that's okay let me ask you this are we
in danger of expectations being so high
that if it's merely good that won't be
good enough with some people yeah
certainly good won't be good enough
right but as long as we're capturing the
feeling I think we're going to be at
least satisfied if it's not good I think
George Lucas is gonna sit there and say
hmm
I told you so here's the main difference
what I think that these movies have is
what the prequels didn't have
collaboration this movie has a lot of
collaboration in whether it comes from
Disney or Lucasfilm and the story team
with JJ - Kathleen Kenny that's the
first there's a lot of creative synergy
day and it's the first time the fans are
making the movie JJ is a fan fellas
let's bottom line it in your head what's
the percentage chance that this movie
could actually be no good 1 2 3 % okay
Wow
just because we've been bit in the ass
before uh-huh I'll say five percent so
Michael as the man behind what if
episode one was good what if episode two
etc what are some things that would have
to take place in this film for you to be
like oh I got another video coming down
the pike I think it would just be
misguided as to the essence of Star Wars
putting a focus on romance or like oddly
racist character is just the sorts of
things that we've already seen before if
that shows up again we've got a problem
what will you do with star wars the
force awakens is not good let us know in
the comments below take us on a journey
into your scary dark place of what's
going to happen if this movie is not
good the best comment we're gonna send
you a screen junkies t-shirt I want to
thank these awesome dudes are being here
Kristian harloff checking out on Mo's no
and Collider Jedi Council michael
barratt ii fellated media looking
forward to your new video I want to
thank you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter by the trailer made
a big mistake by showing us after Batman
V Superman because now we're not
invested in the fight yellows it might
have even affirm made sense to say
spoiler alert they make up